So far in this lecture series, we've assumed
the presence of an image. We've taken an image
from a file. We've taken an image from a camera
attached to our computer. We've grabbed an
image from the Internet. It's time now to
talk about how images are actually formed.
Images are formed within cameras and they
are actually formed on the retina at the back
of our eye. There's a really fascinating aspect
of image formation, we take the three dimensional
world that we live in, that's very real to
us and we project it into two dimensions.
So when we have an image, a photograph or
something like that, it's flat, it's only
two-dimensional. So we've taken three-dimensional things and transformed it into two-dimensional things.
We only had three dimensions to start with,
so we've thrown away one, now we've got two.
There's got to be some consequence of that.
There are some very interesting consequences
of trying to crunch three dimensions down
into two.
But there's another really interesting aspect
of this. And that is if I look at a photograph
of a landscape, it looks three dimensional
to me, even though I know it's flat, it's
a photograph, I can run my hand over it, it
is perfectly flat. So there's some magic going
on in my head, where I'm reconstructing dimensions
that don't actually exist and that just comes
from my own personal experience of the three
dimensional nature of the world; my brain
fills in this extra dimension.
So these are the aspects of image formation
that I want to talk about in this group of
three lectures. In this lecture we're going
to look out how images are formed using pinhole
cameras and cameras with lenses and the treatment
in this lecture is all going to be geometric;
it's about similar triangles. We're also going
to look at a few different types of cameras;
we're going to look at fisheye cameras and
panoramic cameras and a very new type of camera
called a "Light Field Camera".